[Música]
un ex estudiante ecuatoriano en Canadá
fue acusado de cometer tres agresiones
motivadas por el odio ley c-18 de las
noticias en línea Google y meta quieren
que Canadá sirva de ejemplo condenan a
un tercer profesor guatemalteco por
abuso sexual de menor abogados Sin
fronteras Canadá ayuda en el caso
Natalia Lafourcade inauguró el Festival
Internacional de jazz de Montreal
[Música]
qué tal Bienvenidos a su podcast la
actualidad canadiense en 10 minutos del
equipo latinoamericano de radio Canadá
internacional en este fin de junio y
principios de Julio los saluda con el
gusto de siempre Paloma Martínez Estos
son nuestros temas de esta semana
Giovanni villalba alemán fue formalmente
acusado tras un ataque que dejó tres
personas heridas durante un curso sobre
identidad de género en la universidad de
waterloo las tres personas fueron
trasladadas al hospital tras un ataque
con cuchillo en esa Universidad de la
provincia canadiense de Ontario Giovanni
villalba Alemán de 24 años graduado de
una licenciatura en ciencias recibió
acusaciones por tres cargos de agresión
con agravantes cuatro cargos de agresión
con arma dos cargos de posición de un
arma con fines peligrosos y un cargo de
daños menores de cinco mil dólares los
investigadores de la policía Regional de
waterloo creen que se trató de un
incidente motivado por el odio
relacionado con la expresión e identidad
de género
el sospechoso pasó la noche bajo
custodia antes de ser llevado al
tribunal para una comparecencia para
fijar una fianza durante la cual la
policía recomendó que permaneciera
detenido
[Música]
ley c 18 de las noticias en línea Google
y meta quieren que Canadá sirva de
ejemplo Google anunció el jueves que
eliminará los enlaces a noticias
canadienses mientras que meta puso fin a
una serie de acuerdos con medios de
comunicación canadienses la ley de
noticias en línea obligará a los
gigantes del web
a pagar a los medios de comunicación por
compartir sus artículos y reportajes
esta medida adopta del 22 de junio
pasado entrará en vigor dentro de seis
meses
Kent Walker presidente de la división de
negocios globales en Google y su empresa
matriz alphabet señaló que la nueva ley
canadiense adjudica un precio para los
enlaces a contenidos informativos Lo que
implica para su empresa una
responsabilidad financiera sin límite
por se abren comillas simplemente
facilitar a los ciudadanos canadienses
el acceso a noticias de editores de su
país por su parte meta que cobija a
Facebook Instagram y WhatsApp puso fin a
sus acuerdos con varios de los más
importantes medios y agencias de
noticias privados canadienses también en
respuesta a la aprobación de la ley de
noticias en línea en la cámara de los
comunes y el senado canadienses en una
entrevista con radio Canadá el ministro
del patrimonio Pablo Rodríguez se dijo
sorprendido por la nueva postura de
Google según él la ley contempla un
intervalo de seis meses antes de su
entrada en vigor para poder determinarlo
para poder determinar los detalles del
nuevo marco legislativo además señaló
Rodríguez las conversaciones iban bien
Canadá se atrevió a avanzar se atrevió a
enfrentar a los gigantes del web y ellos
no lo aceptaron están intentando enviar
un mensaje no solo a Canadá sino también
a Francia Inglaterra Alemania y Estados
Unidos vamos a seguir manteniéndonos
firmes una cita de Pablo Rodríguez
ministro canadiense del patrimonio
por su parte Michael guys catedrático de
investigación en derecho de internet y
comercio electrónico de la Universidad
de Ottawa afirmó que el ministro
Rodríguez que llevó la legislación al
parlamento no se tomó en serio los
riesgos de lo que calificó de defectuoso
proyecto de ley c18 guyst dijo que el
ministro es totalmente culpable de la
decisión de Google que corre el riesgo
de poner en peligro una industria de la
información ya fragilizada
[Música]
están escuchando la actualidad
canadiense en 10 minutos un podcast
semanal del equipo latinoamericano de
radio Canadá internacional
en otros temas se condena a un tercer
profesor guatemalteco por abuso sexual
de menor abogados Sin fronteras Canadá
brindó apoyo a juristas de las víctimas
de este y de otra veintena de casos el
22 de junio un profesor del municipio
guatemalteco de San Pedro carcha en alta
Verapaz fue declarado culpable de
agresión sexual contra una alumna Maya
que chi de 12 años el tribunal penal
guatemalteco encargado de juzgar los
femicidios y otras formas de violencia
contra las mujeres leyó la sentencia de
este que es el tercer caso de violencia
sexual contra niñas y adolescentes
indígenas en el sistema educativo
Público de Guatemala se trata de la
tercera condena de una veintena de
acusaciones presentadas ante los
tribunales que implican a profesores del
Ministerio de Educación desde el 2021
para Claudia López David directora
nacional y representante de abogados Sin
fronteras Canadá en Guatemala estas
condenas contribuyen a visibilizar una
situación que durante años se ha
beneficiado de la inacción
administrativa por parte de las
autoridades competentes mostrando una
total indiferencia ante la situación de
las niñas dijo dijo López David a la vez
dejan al descubierto el aprovechamiento
de la posición de autoridad y las
desiguales relaciones de poder entre
profesores y alumnos para abusar
sexualmente de las niñas en las escuelas
un gran tabú en las comunidades rurales
de todo el país dijo Claudia López David
directora nacional y representante de
abogados Sin fronteras Canadá en
Guatemala
Y por último Natalia Lafourcade inauguró
el Festival Internacional de jazz de
Montreal
este jueves 28 de junio la cantautora
mexicana Natalia Lafourcade inauguró el
prestigioso Festival Internacional de
jazz y su gira de todas las flores la
primera en Casi cinco años de ausencia
de los escenarios internacionales
originalmente Natalia Lafourcade debía
dar un solo concierto en el marco del
Festival Internacional de jazz de
Montreal sin embargo debido a que se
agotaron las entradas en un tiempo
récord el evento de renombre decidió
abrir otra fecha un día antes de su
inauguración oficial los afiches y las
promociones oficiales del festival
indicaban el jueves 29 de junio como la
fecha de arranque sin embargo un día
antes el 28 de junio Natalia Lafourcade
enamoró a su público creando ambientes
tanto íntimos y emotivos como danzantes
y encendidos en una sala repleta al día
siguiente el 29 de junio repitió la
faena les presentamos una reseña
completa en nuestro sitio internet radio
guión canadá.sea barra oblicua rsi barra
oblicua e s
[Aplausos]
ahí también encontrarán las otras
noticias y reportajes que el equipo
latinoamericano de radio Canadá
internacional les ha preparado esta
semana esto es todo por nuestra parte en
esta ocasión Paloma Martínez en nombre
de todo el equipo les desea un buen fin
de semana y será hasta la próxima
[Música]